last week we were talking about the
exchange
philadel after e4 e5
knight f3 d6 d4
and e takes so we talked all about
these lines last week but i do want to
dedicate a night to what we're going to
talk about
uh this evening are the
bihan ham and lion variations
which have a different kind of nature
than the
exchange i think the exchange is
probably
better than than the lion but i do want
to make sure we cover them because there
are some very aggressive and interesting
plans
for black that we will take a look at
here
i guess first we will start with the
black lion so
for those of you who do not know there
is another move order
you can take to reach philidor type
positions and it's after e4
black plays d6 first and now white
normally plays d4 if your opponent's
giving you the center you might as well
take it and now after d4 there's knight
f6
and knight c3 and rather than g6 which
would lead to appears
black plays knight b to d7
now there is a very distinct difference
between
knight to d7 and pawn to e5
and it's mainly this move here pawn
takes
e5 after pawn takes and pawn takes
white can trade queens and black
forfeits the right to castle now i'm not
saying this
is horrible for black this position is
actually very playable for both sides
but i think black can do better why
trade off the queens and get a very
equal end game
when you can still develop your pieces
and have a totally fine position
so i'm gonna recommend knight b to d7
just to keep your chances not to go into
some
drush and the game where or white is
slightly better
just because they can castle and bring
their rook in a little bit faster
so after knight to d7 there are
three options for white here
um there is g4 f4
and knight f3 now g4 uh i couldn't find
much material on it so i don't
have any lines past this but i would say
this is a real move so if you're black
and you see this
don't think it's garbage it is some kind
of gambit's line
uh reminiscent of the shirov attack
which we'll get into later
but the two main moves that black should
be concerned about
after knight to d7 is knight f3 and f4
so i'm going to start with f4
for a couple reasons one it's probably
different
than most of the other lines we're going
to go over tonight and two
this is actually a position i've
experienced very recently in a
correspondence game
so after f4 white is looking to push
this pawn to e5
try and break through and cramp black's
pieces try and take advantage of the
flak that black has been rather passive
in the center
but black doesn't need to worry about
this rather than worry about white
pushing e5
black can play e5 right here
now you may be wondering what happens if
white decides to capture in the center
now
well after captures on e5 captures e5
captures e5
and now we get this queen trade this
position i think is slightly better than
the previous line we looked at with the
queen trade because now
black is ahead in development this extra
knight in the center
and white now has this isolated e pawn
which is going to be
a very nice target for black so i think
this
this line here is slightly better for
black compared to the previous line
although engines say white is still
slightly better or the position
is equal but um here i may prefer to
have black
just because of the extra development
and clear target
i think the play might be pretty easy
but white is able to develop
rather quickly with moves like bishop f4
knight to f3
bishop d3 could be considered and
castles long
in the near future and kind of the same
story if white captures with the d
pawn this way it can just transpose
either you know just transposed to the
same position here
same thoughts here but
white doesn't need to capture here and
in fact i recommend the move
knight to f3 you just continue
developing your pieces put
more pressure on e5 keep threatening to
win it
and now black really does have kind of
an only move here
a beginner player might think queen e7
is a good move here trying to defend the
pawn again
but the problem after queen to e7 is
knight to b5
threatening c7 which is a big check and
if you have to go
queen d8 to protect it well now your
pawn on e5 is no longer sufficiently
protected because now you have this
knight on f3 that's adding to the attack
so you can't really go queen e7
another move someone might jump at to
defend is knight to g4
but the problem here is after h3 the
knight is just
kicked back and no matter where it goes
uh e5 is falling again
so rather than any of those black really
should be
capturing and should be capturing the
d-pawn
now why the d-pawn over the f-pawn uh
well after
pawn takes f4 bishop takes f4 white is
crushing it
with the development they have nice
space in the center
and black ultimately has traded a center
pawn
for um a bishop pawn here which
generally is not the best of trade you
want to trade center pawns for center
pawns
uh and now e5 will come
with the bishop adding to the control of
e5
so uh i think if you're trying to stick
to the plans for both sides here
black should capture on d4
now i want to give it a little second
here and ask you guys which way
you would recapture on d4 would you
recapture with the knight on f3 or would
you recapture
with the queen on d1
all of a sudden it looks like a good
king's gambit
uh maybe i don't know much about the
king's gambit so i can't speak about it
all right nj fan 9000 saying knight
takes d4 do you have
any other uh anyone disagreeing think
you should capture with the queen
why would you capture with the knight
over the queen
that's what i want to know
what is the reasoning behind it
alright we see another vote for knight
takes d4
montgomery is saying queen takes d4
but i want to see some reasons why i
don't want to see just the move
i want to see some arguments for why
knight captures or
queen captures is better so
solemn is saying knight because queen
should not be moved out early
now how much are you actually thinking
about that general opening principle
after all it's a general principle it's
not a rule
njfan if you capture with the queen then
pawn to c5 attacks the queen and loses a
tempo
might be a fair argument so everyone's
saying
pawn to c5 and there's a tempo loss
let's investigate so
first we'll take a look at queen takes
and
everyone's saying you shouldn't move the
queen out too
early now the reason people say this
your your first
chess coach probably has said this is
because your queen can be attacked
early with moves like knight to c6 or
bishop to c5
currently neither of those options exist
and if black plays pawn to c5 here
well this is no problem for white white
just retreats the queen
and now d6 is going to be a structural
weakness you're going to get
this backwards d-pawn where it's really
not going to be good for black the only
piece is
able to defend it are the bishop and the
queen
maybe you can get the knight defending
it later but something like
bishop to e3 and castles long you're
gonna have a lot of pressure on this
pawn
very early on not to mention e5
is just going to hit it right away and
with white wanting to break with e5
anyway
this is rather good for white so uh i
don't think
those reasons that were given in the
chat are
entirely um accurate
as for why you shouldn't take with the
queen
now we have some people saying knight
takes d4
but let's think about it after knight
takes d4
what is white's plan
i see a lot of people talking about how
knight takes d4 is thematic in many
openings that is very true in
the sicilians you normally take on d4
with the knight
unless you're playing the check over
which we've covered on the channel a
couple weeks ago
but i want to ask you what you're
actually doing next
because to me it's not entirely clear
maybe your knight is looking to go to f5
but black can just stop it with a quick
g6 so what
are you doing zollin is saying bishop to
e2
bishop to e3 queen d2 and castle's long
so you're really just going for this
sicilian setup huh
kind of like a yugoslav attack but with
the pawn on f4 instead
unfortunately this does not go with the
uh most accurate plan for white tier
remember white
is wanting to break with e5 and if you
capture with the knight on d4
this does not help your plan and in fact
after g6 the best move for white is to
move the knight back to f3
to play e5 anyway so are you really okay
spending a tempo with the knight just to
move it back
to play with your plan and in fact after
bishop to g7
by black this is a very very playable
move
i guess currently black has e5 sorry
white has e5
but it doesn't seem to be a big deal for
black after captures
captures queen e7 and here the only move
for white
to keep any advantage it's queen to e2
followed by knight to g4 now this is a
playable line but it's
definitely not easy to find these moves
rather
unnatural if you ask me and you'll only
know these moves if you've
prepped so
if your plan is to break with e5 it
would make a lot more sense to capture
with the queen
because now your knight is still
controlling e5
and your queen is now adding to the
control of e5
and like i said after c5 and something
like queen to d3 or even d2
doesn't really matter which one uh i
think d3
is probably a bit better you can develop
this bishop and castle queen side
early but point is this pawn right here
is backwards it's going to be a huge
weakness
for black in the long run and in fact
i'm running the engine here
off to the side and this position
currently is plus 2.3 with stockfish 13
on depth 30.
so um i'm just
just saying you want to fight the engine
evaluation go right ahead but something
like knight b5
and castle's long it's gonna be really
hard to protect this pawn
so after queen takes d4 best move
for black is to go c6
uh it's all i'm saying why e5 early
though makes black uncramped and frees
up his development does it really free
up his development
let's take a look at this after what is
it knight takes d4
g6 knight f3 bishop g7 e5
early and then after takes takes
queen pretty much has to go to e7
working off of this pin
to make sure your activity is going to
be better because while it looks like
you're ahead in development
your space control is not the same as
whites and you're kind of blocking your
bishops
so you go a little bit early to secure
the space advantage here
and then knight to g4 something like
bishop to g5 here just attacking the
queen
when you actually take a look at it when
the lines open up it's a lot easier for
white to develop the pieces than black
mainly because this
knight is blocking the bishop and it's
going to be hard to get all of the
pieces to their ideal squares
so that would be an argument for why e5
earlier
well okay let's move on we'll cover
queen takes d4 and black will almost
always play c6 here
after c6 white can go ahead with rather
natural development
go bishop to e3 and
there is this idea of pawn d5
breaking well not really breaking but
more fighting
for the center now that it's prepared
with the pawn so this is one of the
ideas of c6 is that after c6 you control
d5
so now you can play d5 on the next move
and here there are two moves i want to
look at with
white first we will take a look at e5
uh hello adam thanks for joining us and
after e5 black has two different options
first is bishop to c5 which was actually
played against me
in this correspondence game i mentioned
earlier and
white is good to go ahead with just
sorry queen to d2
captures captures and after knight to g4
just
bring the queen back to d2 and white is
slightly better here
mainly because of the space on the queen
side and it's rather hard to see
where black's pieces definitely want to
go uh
this knight on d7 maybe wants to go to
c5 maybe b6 but
your queen really wants to go to b6 to
put pressure
maybe have some ideas of a mate and in
fact one idea is
queen to b6 and white can actually
castle here
for those of you who have not seen this
trap before after knight to f2
there is knight to a4 and there's no way
for the queen to
to move and keep the knight defended so
after something like 94
attacking the queen just capture capture
and after captures on c8
um there's really no good move for black
here white is going to end up a piece if
they take on f3 you can play knight d6
as an inner mezzo
check the king and save your knight
so that is one trap from bishop c5 um
so all black needs to worry about is
after castle's long don't play knight f2
play something um a bit more natural to
the development like knight c5 maybe get
this knight on e4 bring the bishop out
that's going to be much better for for
black the other option they have is to
go knight g4 right away hitting the
bishop
and all white needs to do is drop the
bishop back to g1
this looks rather odd because you're
you're bringing the bishop back to the
first rank
but this bishop is going to be a better
piece than the knight and you're not too
concerned about
taking up the squares on the first rank
on the king's side you're wanting to
castle queen side
anyway so now after something like queen
b6
you can trade queens and this should be
a fine position for white just play h3
kicking the knight
knight goes to h6 and now g4 you're
expanding on
the king side you have your bishops that
are watching the queen side
there's a lot of activity here and
really i think the only move
that's really great for black is knight
to
g8 looking to go to e7
because otherwise your knights going to
get get harassed further more if you try
something else
i don't know knight c5 here
just pawn f5 and there there's this big
advance
coming on the king side
so after e5 um
black can get away with knight g4 i
think this is the better try
otherwise white has this option of
capturing on
d5 white captures on d5
and bishop to c5 here protected by the
knight
queen d3 just protecting the bishop
and now one move black has here is queen
to e7
and this is just putting more pressure
on the bishop
now one of the moves that white has at
their disposal here is a little creative
is knight to d4 uh montgomery in the
chat
is asking what happens when bishop c5 is
played after knight g4 bishop g1
and then bishop c5 good question
uh let's actually take care of that
before we move on so knight g4 bishop g1
and bishop c5
here just queen d2 bring the queen back
and if there's a
takes on g1 and rook takes on g1 this
isn't a problem
the knight is controlling h2 so you can
still play h3 kick the knight out and go
g4 and i think this actually helps white
as the rook is now going to be helping
to support
some of the the pawns that are further
up the board
so hopefully that answers your question
i guess queen v6 is a move you need to
worry about here because there is this
um what looks to be a fork but remember
your knight on f3
is doing a very good job controlling
stuff just go knight a4 to attack the
queen
protect the pawn and there's no square
for the queen to go to
to harass the knight so queen to e3 is
probably their best move and trade the
queens
and you're doing fine here just continue
with your development i don't see any
problems for
for white now i'm not saying
white is fantastically better but there
are no
um obvious problems
but very good question okay so takes on
d5 bishop c5
queen d3 queen e7 and the creative
knight
d4 there's two moves for black here one
i thought was very
interesting was knight to b6
and this is sacrificing a pawn on c6
and black is really looking to generate
peace activity the engines aren't a big
fan of this
but it seems to me that in human
practice
black is doing fine here um maybe a bit
of a struggle
but um they're still scoring in these
lines so
white should continue by taking on c6
and after the b-pawn takes back
they should castle queen side and it
looks
to to me that white is kind of
untangling their pieces
there was obviously a lot of pressure on
e3 from the king's placement on e1
but after you castle queenside i don't
see how black takes huge advantage of
this
and if white is trying to i guess
continue
or i guess it's black's move so
something like bishop a6 has been
recommended
and the idea is that if you take on a6
you're losing
on d4 it takes on e3 and it's a fork
so rather than take on a6 you have to
play queen d2 this is
you know something you need to watch out
for don't take what appears to be a free
piece because you're actually losing
another just go queen d2 and okay if
they take on f1
um this is a little bit of a tricky
situation you want to just take
but after knight c4 you're losing
so the move you need to know here is
bishop 2f2
and the idea is that if they ever move
this bishop back
to to try and defend it well now you
have rook to e1
and you're going to be winning a queen
so
uh there are quite a few tactics in this
line but i do think white
gets a bit of an upper hand uh as long
as they know you know
castle long and then be careful about
what looks to be a free bishop
drop the queen back drop the bishop back
threatening rookie one
uh nj phantom bishop takes d4 white is
up the bishop pair
that's true and looks like adam is
appreciating the tactic
okay so uh yeah knight b6 sacrificing
the pawn a very interesting idea
don't think it's the absolute best
though i think
knight to g4 is a bit more active
still piling up pressure on e3
so this e3 square is definitely
getting some pressure and i want to see
if anyone can find the best move
for white here um it was definitely a
move that
i would consider as a candidate but if i
saw this position fresh for the first
time i might be a little nervous to play
it
we'll see if we have any guesses
hello james lee from quad cities
knight f5 all right montgomery in the
chat
has suggested knight f5 and this is the
move here
knight of five is attacking the queen
simultaneously
defending e3 another time
uh now it looks like e3
isn't uh protected enough you only have
two defenders and there are three
attackers
but again the the big thing here is that
you are also attacking the queen
you're also threatening knight g7 takes
with
check which is a resource you may be
able to use later
now knight d2e5
is a move here a very strange looking
move attacking the queen
and putting itself in the way of being
captured by the pawn
now here i think white's best
continuation is to take on e7 and trade
the queens off
and now after bishop takes knight knight
takes bishop
there is knight takes bishop on c8 rook
takes c8
and now d takes uh c6 rook takes c6
and you're entering this rather even
position
we see pawn g3 kind of building the pawn
chain here
we see castles from black king e2 and
bishop
d4 is just an example of how this line
can go
and i think that this is a rather
good try from black their pieces are
definitely they're developed and white
still needs to get their rooks in the
center but i think
black's pieces are missing a little bit
of coordination here
and it's a little hard to see exactly
how they get the attack through but
i'm imagining this rook is going to come
to c8 or
over to d8 or e8
all right um i think we had some other
guesses
in the position after
knight to g4 um
to do we had a suggestion for castling
queen side
this just hangs a piece after queen
takes e3
and then bishop to b5 pinning the rook
uh i'm assuming that's in reference to a
different position
um
i'm assuming that is after this so if
you go
bishop to b5 pinning the rook here
there's knight c2 so
you're actually losing a pawn here
because they're going to get the
exchange back on a1
but that's a good question as well seems
like an obvious tactic but
your bishop does have a role defending
so if you want to try that
maybe you can try king d2 they castle
and but i mean like after the castle you
don't have a pin anymore so
i definitely need to watch out for
black's counter tactics
black definitely has a lot of tricks
they can play for in these lines
but i would say i am a a big fan of both
sides definitely stuff to play for
but that kind of covers the main line of
the black lion
um at least or sorry of the
anti-philidor
rather this is not the black line this
is the the anti-philidor with f4
um with that being said uh
let's move into the black line with
knight to f3
uh hopefully there aren't too many
questions about the f4 lines anymore but
uh i do want to make sure we're still
moving along here knight to
f3 and now pawn to e5 and this is
uh what we we know as the lion
so after e5 uh sorry white's best move
is probably bishop to c4 one of the most
popular moves here
um i guess another move here is g4 with
the shirov gambit which i guess i'll
i'll cover
um real briefly here knight takes g4
rook g1 and there's a sacrifice of a
pawn
after the knight retreats to f6 we see
some development from white with the
bishops breaking in the center a little
bit
uh queen d3 protecting the pawn again
and after b5 bishop to b3 queen a5
and castles long white does have
a lot of development whereas black is
struggling a little bit with the bishops
but bishop a6 here is fine knight d2
rook to d8 and now queen f1
and this position is rather balanced
even though white is down a pawn
again all their pieces are developed to
reasonable squares
and black is going to be struggling to
develop the bishop because of this g
pawn so g6 is probably necessary here
and now the queen will move to the king
side and help attack over here but
definitely an interesting line uh again
a little hard to find
theory on some of these but i do want to
just expose you guys to these lines
that they do exist and can be worth a
shot
but okay the the main move is bishop to
c4
and black will normally go bishop to e7
we see castles by white i guess knight
g5
is another move here but i think after
castles
is going to be fine so okay castles from
white
and c6
um the other move here is black castling
uh in this line and then we see rookie 1
c6 a4 b6 uh bishop to a2 and a6
so some of these moves may look weird
from black but really all that's
happening here is they are bringing the
pawns up to be rather flexible
and they can control which break they
want to go for something kind of like
kind of reminds me of a hedgehog how you
have pawns on a6 b6
d6 and e6 a little different here but
uh this this is what's happening on the
black side is that white isn't making
many threats
um so they're just advancing their pawns
uh kind of controlling the queen side
here
but okay again c6 and white has this
move
a4 after a4 there are
a few moves by black
we'll look at h6 now there are
some tricks that um that white
has or i guess there's move order tricks
in these positions
um there's also a5 here this kind of
limits white's play on the queen side
but that's about as much analysis as i'm
going to give this
i don't think it's as popular but i do
want to mention h6
and now white can continue with
something like
b3 queen c7 and bishop to b2
and in the lion black will normally want
to play something like g5
bring the knight to f8 and to g6 but if
the bishop is here on b2 on the queen
side
you don't really want to be playing g5
this will open yourself up to some
tactics that
can hurt you rook to e1 is a good move
here and let's say black continues with
this plan of knight f8
here white is already winning after d
takes e5
and then if they take back uh there
excuse me there is knight two uh e5
captures
and if the queen takes knight d5
and after knight d5 there there's
really no great spot for the queen if
you try going to
d6 knight takes f6 uh if bishop takes
then queen takes the queen if queen
takes
you lose the queen to the bishop so
after knight d5
f6 is falling or the queen is going to
be captured so
uh let's say after queen b2 this is
already made in one
so lots of traps black can fall for in
these lines
so you want to be careful of the move
order after a4 you do want to go
queen c7 first and now white will
normally play
h3 this is kind of to keep the knights
out
and black will play h6 if black tries to
play knight f8 a little too soon
he's met with knight g5 and this puts
the the attack on f7 and there's no
great way to
defend it so to avoid all of this black
should just play
h6 right away bishop to e3
and now knight f8 and uh g5 is also
also has been played here but um
according to at least
grandmaster simon williams who uh has a
little preview of his course on youtube
um he thinks knight f8 is a little bit
more flexible here and i have to agree
uh if you play g5 you can open yourself
up to
to some move order tricks that we just
looked at and after knight to f8
sometimes it can be unclear if you want
to play g5 now or later
for instance uh sometimes it can be
better to go knight g6
and then f4 and then g5 particularly
if let's say they go b3 and
now knight f8 bishop to b2 well now
knight g6 is actually faster
this looks faster to get to knight for
because they can't capture on f4 with
the bishop
and then let's say you go knight f4 in
the future and then they bring the
bishop back
well then you can play g5 and support
the knight
so okay bishop to e3 knight f8
rookie one and in this particular
instance
um g5 i guess could be played
maybe not because uh of this tactic here
this still exists if the bishop is on e3
as well
uh so knight takes e5 and if they take
bishop d4
now and if something like queen to d6
well e5 is a four
right away so here
i think this move order is not correct
with
g5 i think you have to go knight g6 and
then
and then forward but this was one of the
uh
one of the traps black and fall for
sorry my notes are a little out of order
here
i was rushing a little bit last night to
get them so i do apologize
but i guess that's kind of a overview of
the the lion here i'm trying to see if i
can find
a better move order but it looks like i
have not
put in the main order here but
uh something like uh yeah h3h6 is fine
i think everything here is fine i think
it's just g5 there is this little
tactical shot so you should go knight g6
first
um but really if the bishop is is not on
e3 or b2
uh i think playing g5 first is fine
okay um what else is
happening in this opening i think that
covers the lion
and the shirov gambit and it also covers
the anti-philidor
and that's all the lines you you can
really expect from d6
there are some other sidelines that
black should be
uh aware of before they start playing it
in tournaments probably
but now we're going to move on back to
this e5 move order
so e5 knight f3 d6 d4
and now we're going to cover um knight
to
d7 here and this is the hen m variation
and i think this is like the last major
variation and most of
the lines here i guess moves most of my
analysis here isn't going to be over the
best moves
is actually going to be going over what
happens if black doesn't play the best
move because
there are a lot of natural moves that
actually lose on the spot so we're gonna
look at bishop to c4
and this is my recommendation is the
most popular move here
and plenty of ways for black to go wrong
um it also looks like black has
like two good options here but let's
start by covering
the poor options i want to get some
recommendations from the chat what do
you guys think is the best move
after bishop c4 how does black continue
all right you have one suggestion for c6
two suggestions why bishop c4
why not you're developing a piece you're
opening yourself up to castle
giving yourself the opportunity for
knight g5 an attack on f7
why wouldn't you play bishop c4
all right now we're seeing some more
natural
suggestions of knight to b6 knight f6
bishop e7
in the philidor is it best to castle
kingside or queenside
for which color if it's for black it
looks to normally be king side for white
it
it depends
okay so let's uh look at these
natural moves before we start getting
some
some more chess professors in the chat
here
um okay let's first take a look at
knight f6
knight g to f6 looks very natural
putting pressure on e4
looks like the way to go but this just
unfortunately
is not the case you take on e5
and now if their pawn takes knight to g5
and there's no way to stop either piece
from taking on f7
so that
refutes at least the pawn captures now
what if the knight captures here is uh
knight captures e5 knight captures e5
de5 and there's a tactical shot here
that white has uh with
bishop to f7
now the big idea here is if black
takes it looks like you're winning a
queen but don't get your
your hopes too high here uh you are not
winning the queen you're rather just
winning
um this pawn on f7 because there is
bishop to before check
the queen drops back to d2 because the
the rook over here is attacking it
so you drop back to d2 and after bishop
takes
knight takes d2 or um
yeah bishop d2 doesn't actually work
here because e4 hangs and now
black is starting to get some counter
play and their material back
so just knight takes d2 protect e4 play
f3 and then move the knight away
white is going to have a better game
here
so knight g to f6 does not quite
work so sorry for those who thought
that move there's also the idea of
bishop to e7
which falls for something very similar
captures on e5
and now if pawn captures queen d5
threatening mate and there's no good way
to stop it
if you go knight h6 trying to stop it
there's bishop h6
and if you take the bishop then you are
checkmated
so you can't take the bishop you have to
castle you're already down a piece
so now bishop to e3 white lights up a
piece
and should expect to win the game
okay uh
if you take and then
i actually just covered this yeah if
knight takes um
i guess after knight takes is uh i
didn't cover this line
rather than queen d5 where a queen trade
can occur
queen h5 is the refutation
and now after g6 there's queen takes e5
hitting the rook
knight to f6 and now bishop h6 is going
to win you the game
with the threat of bishop g7 forking
because after um like bishop g7 rook g8
the bishop can take on f6
and then ice is actually just hanging
the the bishop is pinned to the king
so here black uh has tried rook to g8
but with everything kind of pinned black
no longer being able to castle king
side uh this is not looking too great
for black you can just continue with
knight c3
you can bring a rook to d1
castle all your pieces are in the game
you're attacking
black's pieces are pinned i don't think
i need to explain further
okay um we're getting question after
bishop to b4
why not c3 in which
line was there bishop to b4
in knight f6 yes
uh well if you go c3 they take on d8
and yes you get the bishop but your pawn
structure is a little ruined and e4
hangs
so you need to go knight or sorry queen
to d2
it's very important that you get your
knight to be able to
protect the pawn so this is why this is
why you don't go
c3 you preserve your pawn structure and
your material good question
but okay those are refutations for
knight g to f6
and bishop to e7 now if black has
fallen for these traps before they may
try and be innovative
and play h6 to stop these ideas
however this is also uh pretty poor for
black after
captures on e5 if pawn captures
there's bishop takes f7 now the king
cannot take well okay king has to take
rather
uh but it runs into knight takes e5 and
the king is
checked and this knight cannot take
because
the queen hangs and now there is no
bishop b4
uh because after c3 the bishop is
attacked and you don't have this rook
attacking the queen
so knight can't take what does
black do well if they go king to e7
there's knight g6 and it has this fork
right away
if they tried king e6 there's queen d5
and it's running into mate after
something like king e7 queen f7
king d6 knight c4 is a move
king c5 queen d5
and you have this really interesting
mate with the pawns in the corner here
and you have something very similar if
the king goes to e8 it's just a couple
moves longer
there's already forced maintenance 7 and
if you don't play this
the position is considered equal but the
best moves queen h5
after g6 you take they move the king to
e7
queen f7 king d6 knight c4
and again you chase this king down to
your corner
and you can play either c3 or a3 both
are made in two
and let's see i guess the only other
move here
is king to f6 so after king to f6
there's this very interesting second
piece sacrifice with knight c3
if the king takes the knight this is
disaster
queen d5 king goes to f6 only move
and now queen to f5 forcing the king to
e7
now the only move you have here is
knight d5 check forcing the king to d6
if he goes back here then this is just
mate after queen g6 so be aware that
this is a mate
don't see king e8 and freak yourself out
this is mate right here so king d7
and now you bring another piece into the
game bishop f4
check king c6 queen e6
forcing bishop to d6 and now the only
winning move
here knight to b4 trek the bishop cannot
take because it's pinned
now no matter where the king goes white
is going to have a winning advantage and
in most cases
a mate so
i guess we can look at king c5 of king
c5
then something as simple as bishop e3
and if they
take then queen to d5 and you're going
to have again
a very similar mate with the pawns
the only try they really have after
knight to b4 is king b6
but bishop takes and then okay if you
take back
queen takes d6 this is not looking good
for the home team king a5
knight d5 and you're already running
into very big problems
but i think most of the moves after
knight b4 should come
pretty naturally as long as you take
your your time to think
um what else is happening here
i don't think there's any other
serious move uh so now let's take a look
at knight captures so
uh again after h6 we take on e5
now if the knight captures
knight takes e5 d takes e5 and again we
have
bishop f7 now here in this line with the
knight on g8 you cannot
simply take and expect a queen b4 you do
have to play king e7
and after king e7 there is queen f3
protecting the bishop
and now knight to f6 and this is a
little bit of a tricky move
because this is threatening bishop to g4
um and really kind of trapping the queen
uh because if let's say a3
well bishop g4 and if your queen moves
away
here checkmated so rather than allow
bishop to g4
we we beat this early by playing queen
b3
and getting ready to castle so now if
like bishop g4 getting ready castle well
f3 is good right away castles is good
white is better so h6
also a rather poor choice
okay um
see a couple more chat messages here
um we see no one plays the philidor
nowadays for a reason well i'm not
i want to be clear i'm not saying the
philip door is garbage
i'm saying that these specific lines are
garbage
um the black in the philidor actually
does have some pretty challenging lines
uh as far as um white trying to gain an
advantage
so it's very easy to dismiss the
philidor because everybody is just like
oh yeah it sucks you should just play
knight c6 because it's better
but when you actually take a look at
some of the lines white actually does
have
quite a few tricks they need to watch
out for so someone caught off guard
may struggle against the philidor and i
know people can get to
very high levels in chess by playing
playing it
so i wouldn't say that this opening is
particularly
fantastic for white i would probably
prefer white in most lines
but black does have a couple a couple
good shots here
okay um yeah epic wolves in the chat
saying everyone usually takes on d4 yeah
like i said i think the exchange is
probably a better try for black
but okay let's get into the real moves
we just looked at the moves that don't
work for black here
uh we are running short on time so i'm
going to try and get through all these
in the next
seven minutes um e takes d4
and again we're going to play queen
takes d4
contrary to popular belief this is a
good move
because there's no attack on the queen
if c5
like earlier we can actually get away
with queen d5
or if you don't want to mix up your
lines just play queen d3 every time
and you will be better d6 is just too
big of a weakness
now bishop f4 knight to c3 to b5
castle's long everything is going to
pile up on it
so after queen takes d4 now you see the
knight develop
knight to c3 bishop e7 bishop f4
castles castles long knight b6
and here there's two ways white can play
if you really love your bishop pair and
can't live without it you can just drop
it back to b3
but if you're really wanting to follow
the spirit of the opening
rook h2e1 here is a very nice
alternative because here
you're just saying all right you can
take my bishop take the bishop pair
but i'm way ahead in development here
all of my pieces are developed
see the bishops are good the knights are
good rooks are in the center
pawn has control over the center
um for those of you who
[Music]
are taught chess from a friend you
probably see that this is like the best
opening set up white ever has also
sometimes referenced as god's opening
um but this is this is about as good as
it gets for white
um and okay if the knight takes well
queen takes and again just your way
ahead in development
white is going to be just fine here
why is having the bishop pair so good or
is it just
preference um so if you
have two knights in an end game versus a
lone king you cannot force mate
if you have two bishops versus a lone
king you can force mates that's one
two um if you have the bishops working
together they can actually control more
squares than the knights together can
however there are benefits for knights
over bishops knights can control
both colored squares while bishops can
only control the color square they are
on um so in like very closed
positions knights can actually be
preferred
because they can maneuver around the
board a bit better
but i would say at the higher levels the
higher you go you start to value the
bishops a little bit more just because
they
they can control more squares they can
control from farther away
but i would say you know below 1800
probably just preference i don't think
it's
it's too important
what happens after bishop to g4 after
rook h to e1
well here um now if you're just looking
to improve your position
they are threatening to to trade a
knight for bishop which does give a
material imbalance
so whether or not you're a big fan of
the bishop fair or not material
imbalances are something you want to
think about
but one thing you can do is just go
bishop to e2
this prevents your pawns from getting
doubled it breaks the pin
stops them from being able to capture
and get your queen off the file
i think this is a rather nice move it
looks a little counterintuitive because
you're blocking the rook
but you're gonna play h3 and kick this
bishop away
but i think that should be fine for
white if they capture on d4
and honestly if they're going to capture
on d4 they should probably be playing
the exchange
uh philadelph by taking a move earlier i
think after knight d7
and bishop c4 i think this gives white
just a little bit
too much of a leading development
but okay now the real line uh the real
line
is c6 here uh c6 i think is the most
played move and this starts to mirror
some of the um
other lines we were looking at earlier
and now white has a couple different
ways to play knight g5 is one because
you're going after f7 right away
and the only move is knight h6 after
knight h6
there is um a4 i'm gonna get back to
this in just a second
because i have that as my main line
there's also castle
short which is a very solid move and a
lot of uh
very strong grandmasters have played
this in tournament games
where black will go bishop to e7 there's
a capture on
e5 and regardless of which way black
captures
knight captures is actually worse this
is pretty good for white
after queen h5 this is actually winning
plus three
if g6 then captures on e5 hitting the
rook
we've seen this idea before this is
actually just a transposition from one
of our other lines
and then um if you don't want to castle
short
then there is what is it
a4 a4 is another alternative
here um but i'm gonna stick with knight
g5 as another line you can play
and then uh knight h6 again only move
and now a4
bishop e7 and uh bishop e7 is actually a
blunder here
um bishop b7 is not the best move for
black the best move is actually to uh
to play e takes um there's also another
idea of queen f6
that uh i'll cover
but i do want to cover bishop e7 so this
is another one of those
like natural looking moves that's
actually pretty bad
um there's a tactic of bishop f7
knight f7 and then knight to e6
hitting the queen and after queen to a5
after queen a5 it runs into bishop to d2
and after queen b6 there's a5 hitting
the queen
uh you can't ever go to a6 because of
the fork
so queen to b2 and bishop c3
traps the queen the other line they have
is after knight e6
going to b6 but this is still losing
after a5 again they can never go to a6
because of the fork
queen b4 check c3 and
excuse me queen c4 and sometimes black
may think they're getting away with this
but there's this very very nice
move knight to c7 check
i don't know who's saying i'm only a
thousand rated but uh that's not correct
um but okay sorry i was just uh got
distracted by the comments section there
um but okay after knight c6 check king
d8 looking like it's going to win
the night the blowout move
is pawn b3 and the queen actually is
trapped
the knight is controlling this diagonal
the queen can get out
uh is controlling this diagonal and the
queen can't move laterally because of
the pawns
so queen is trapped here and this is all
pretty much
forced after bishop to e7 so rather than
bishop e7 you can try
queen f6 after queen f6 white can
continue pawn c3
just reinforcing the pawn and now after
bishop to e7
you can castle short and i think white
is still doing fine here
blackened castle and then uh it's it's
plus one here for white but um
i think it's just pretty good because
this knight on d7 looks a little
awkwardly placed and this bishop
is struggling to develop early
so okay i think the best move for black
here is just pawn takes d4
and we're going to go with queen takes
d4
in most of these lines queen takes d4 is
completely fine and probably the best
move it does help this plan
of playing e5 and there's no
way for them to really attack the queen
if they try like queen b6
um you know it's
you play bishop e3 and hope for a trade
that should be fine for white
but uh i mean there's no big problems
black can pose this
position is pretty passive for black uh
95 is the best move here hitting the
bishop
and uh now you just castle um
and if they take i mean you can take
with the queen and this is
a equal position here
but we are running a little bit over i
want to make sure we still have
some time for questions
um and see if there's any any lines that
anybody has any dying questions about
before we move over to twitch
kind of crazy we did all that analysis
and we're only nine moves deep
what's my twitter i don't have a twitter
i stay off
off of twitter
alrighty any questions related to the
position though
any questions about the filo door any
line any major lines that i missed over
the last two lectures
i want to make sure i don't have to give
a third but if there are
are important lines i want to make sure
we can get them out
but i think we covered all the main
lines here
all right well i don't see any other
questions coming in
um
sorry ramon that you just entered and
we're wrapping up
um but if you're still interested in a
chess lecture we're about to move over
to twitch where we're going to be going
through the next three rounds of the
winner's circle
uh with vasilis mislove in the 1953
candidates
we are getting very close to the end of
that tournament and
we actually let's get to see uh the
first
loss of his in the tournament so
definitely pop on over there
i'll see you guys there in just a few